parmi les sorties de mercredi sur vos
grands écrans président d'un jour une
comédie politique américaine peu
ordinaire en effet remplacé au pied levé
le président américain dans certaines
circonstances celle aventure qui arrive
aux braves citoyens kevin klein qui se
retrouve avec sigourney weaver comme
époux ce qui n'est pas ce qui peut
arriver de pire dans la vie
reportage nicolas nicole canlers
langlois et bernard ronfler et soeurs
lui c'est le président des états unis il
est fatigué cet homme là voyez vous
alors son entourage décide d'utiliser un
sosie pour les corvées cédait un brave
type
et c'est kevin klein j'en pince sans
rire qui interprètent les deux un jour
dave doit remplacer complètement le
président tombé dans le coma par excès
d'amour dirons nous c'était à la fois un
véritable défi et un trio mais les deux
personnels devaient être semblable en
surface et intérieurement à l'opposé
aussi l'été drôle de trouver le portrait
psychologique juste et précis de chacun
avez vous pris un président comme modèle
j'ai pris différentes sortes de
référence un peu de lyndon johnson un
peu de george bush
un peu de kennedy un peu de reggae et
même peut-être un peu de hitler replacer
le président dans sa vie privée mais
parfois dave dans des situations
embarrassantes
surtout avec sa femme c'est une comédie
à la frank capra tout en nuance le
charme de cette histoire reposer sur la
nette opposition entre gènes l'ingénuité
dave et le cynisme politique du vrai une
ambiguïté qui continuent à obséder kevin
klein de ce que vous préférez le
personnage du
d où une question assez loin du
président alors je vais faire le ménage
d'été parce que il est plus longtemps
sur les clubs très intéressant merci
beau coupé